So It Begins
[Music]
when I was young I was blinded by love
now look on what remains of me
may I ask what is your intention
I believe once you have made your
fortune love is not so hard to find And
So It Begins I'm a common boy
now a handsome man innocent
[Music]
for the great corruption
[Applause]
I'm looking for a Boy by the name
bring him to London and teach him
teach me what
the Wicked Ways of this wicked City do
you feel love
Mr Jack this has insisted that you stay
under my protection
foreign
[Music]
of Revenge
look at me
be used against all men you cannot even
think about marrying that idiot
you really want to win a stroller you
will need more than love
everything I tell you to do
how's your new boots are waterproof we
are walking through water no
I'm gonna be walking
through rivers of blood
[Applause]
Estella
what a prize creature we have fished
from the river
[Music]